For the first problem, we have the quantity negative 5 squared. We have negative
5 twice and negative 5 times negative 5 is positive 25. For the second problem,
we have the negative of 8 to the 0. Remember, when I have a negative sign out in
front, it's a negative 1. So, negative 1 times 8 to the 0. Any number raised to
the 0 power is just 1 so we have negative 1 times 1, negative 1 is our answer.
Number 3 is pretty tricky. We have 1 to the 100. It might be tempting to right
100 as the answer but we really know that this is 1 times 1 times 1 a 100 times.
This is a lot of ones. But we know when we multiply all these ones together,
we'll just end up with 1. For number four, we have the negative of 5 squared
minus 2 squared. This negative sign out in front is really negative 1 times 5
squared, so I'm only needing to square the 5, I don't square the negative 1.
This is the big difference between number one and number four. In number one, we
had the quantity, negative 5 squared. Here, we only have the negative of 5
squared. So, we just square the 5. Five squared is 25 times negative 1 is
negative 25. Then, I have a minus 4 on the end. Two squared is four. Negative 25
minus 4. Well, I have negative 25 and negative 4. So, that's more negatives. I
have negative 29. And finally for number 5, we have the quantity, negative 4
plus 7 squared. Remember, we can't distribute the square over the sum. We need
to add these numbers together first, then do the square. Negative 4 and 7 make 3
and 3 squared is simply 9. If you got at least half of these right, excellent
work. Some of these were a little bit tricky, so it's okay if you didn't get all
of them right, but I'm sure you will next time.